y las calles de barcelona normalmente
llenas de gente han estado inusualmente
tranquilas estas navidades en medio de
los crecientes contagios de kobe 19
cataluña impuso esta semana nuevas
restricciones como el toque de queda de
unas 6 de la madrugada el cierre de
discotecas y la limitación del aforo en
lugares públicos algunos de los
asistentes de la escena nocturna no
pareció importarles claro en otras
ocasiones hemos ido a celebraciones
grandes en sitios abiertos pero como
todas las cosas preferimos estar solo en
filipinas los fieles se sintieron
aliviados al poder volver a las iglesias
y celebrar la navidad aunque se
aplicaron varias normas para limitar el
riesgo de contagio en tailandia ocurrió
lo mismo esta semana el país reportó su
primer grupo de positivos en la variante
omicron altamente contagiosa para
celebrar esta misa tenemos que aplicar
medidas como controles de temperatura y
la norma de distanciamiento social y
también tenemos que limitar los
asistentes que no van con luján mientras
tanto en australia muchos pasaron la
navidad de aislados las clínicas de
análisis estaban desbordadas sin embargo
algunos de los que lo celebraron se
refrescaron en la playa mientras que en
otros lugares como bondi la gente posaba
para las fotos mientras los socorristas
voluntarios patrullaba las orillas